Chính bay tới trên của chính phủ, bố trường bộ công an đứng tâm quan cho biết.
Dự thảo được xây dựng trên tắt màu đảm sự em mình của pháp luật.
Không có phung cấm, không có ngoài lệ.
Đông thời xem sẽ bản dựng đồng cơ, mối cạnh, hậu quả và thích quả khóc cuộc để sự bí phu hợp.
Thế hiện, tính nhân văn quanh hồng của đảm, nhả nước.
Dự thảo để xuất một số cơ trên mới như không chuyện cứ hoặc lại chứa chắc nghiệp hình sự.
Đối với rủ gió trong hả nổ phòng không, đối mới sáng tạo và chuyện được số.
Tạm hoảng miễn chuyện kêu chắc nhẹ mình sự trong một số trường ở đủ điều kiệt.
Đồng thời quy định cơ chế sự lý kiến lật tương ứng đối với cả nổ, công trước.
Kết lượng phィên học, phó chủ tịch của gọi của hả nổ dây en cho biết,
bói bán thường của gọi cơ bản thân nhất với sự cần thiết bàn hành nghị quế.
Và đồng ý, chính của gọi xem sẽ tải kỳ học trên đề tháng tạm, hả nổ của trong hai sấu.
Phó chủ tịch của gọi của hả nổ dây en nghị.
Tích tục hả n thiện tên gọi, phạm bi đều trình, lối tượng ám dụng.
Tất cả các bạn sản thảo, tích tục nghiên cứu đề có nhiều hơn những chính xách đột phá trong dự thảo lột như
xem sẽ chuyển đổi từ cơ chếu đại đầu tư sau cảnh tranh tạm câu
phân cấp, phân quyền mạnh mẽ trong hội đồng.
Các thành quyền của thập đoàn công nghiệp nặng lượng cúch ra trong việc quy định các dự án nhóm bê,
giống xe để chủ đồng chữ trách nhiệp, giảm mất việc xin đi kiến các cơ quan đại diện
chủ dưới ứng của nhà nước.
Già Soát, phần thiện các quy định về cơ chế, đại và khách thách tận thù đối với mỏ,
lâu dầu khi, và đảm gió dàng, ở bỉ khả thịt, hiểu quả trong tổ chức tự hiệp.